[Music]
cynthia is in
philadelphia hi cynthia how are you hi
hi dave oh my god i can't believe i'm
actually speaking with you
um i i'm 60 years old and
to be honest i'm not sure if i'll ever
be able to retire
i i was working a second job but
last year i had some health issues so
i'm not able to work a second job and
then covet hit i still have my regular
job though
but i'm a baby step three but uh i'm
only able to save like
200 to pay or like 400 a month i i
and it's going to take me until next
year
ends up next year just to save my
emergency fund which should be about 9
300.
i'm i i just don't know what else to do
and i'm i'm doing your
your your the budget i i just don't know
what else to do
what do you make i make seventy six
hundred dollars i bring home
like 1900 to pay i i live in
philadelphia so they take out the
municipality taxes
i'm sorry you make seventy six thousand
dollars a year
seventy six hundred dollars a month no
nineteen hundred dollars what was the 76
that's a year seventy six thousand a
year
but it's nineteen hundred dollars a
paycheck which is what 3 800
a month i have a mortgage yeah that's
like
way off that's only four that's
that's forty six thousand dollars a year
you don't make 76 and have 30 in taxes
i live in florida i know you live in
philadelphia even philadelphia is not
that communist
well i pay i okay we
i have a pension they so they take out
money for your pension i
have money go to a disability and i pay
my health insurance
and um
oh no cynthia and her phone bill oh my
gosh
lost her uh oh no okay well keep keep
going though
listening that are 60 well 70 76
4 000 a month 1900 times two
is 48 a year okay
and 48 a year is not take-home pay from
a 76 000
gross um unless she's
uh oh god we got her back that was quick
good are you there cynthia
cynthia pick her up again well we'll
just keep working on this till we get it
hey
are you there i'm here okay your call
dropped out sorry
okay so anyway we need to really dig
into this take-home pay because
how much is your health insurance um
it's like twenty dollars a pay okay how
much
is your uh pension deduction how much
are they taking out for the pension
it's like 170 173 dollars
okay i haven't found it yet i need
something that's over a thousand
your said your pay is 76 000.
that means we have 30 000 missing
2500 a month 2 500 a month
so far you gave me about hundred dollars
worth of stuff
i still can't find the two thousand but
taxes cynthia is what you're saying
seventy six thousand are you getting a
huge tax refund
no last year i got it was like nine
hundred dollars
okay not it either your federal income
taxes aren't that high
philadelphia does have some weird taxes
but they should not amount to
uh 30 of your income as a matter of fact
i know they don't
okay and so i tell you what i'm gonna
have you get with one of our financial
coaches that have been through the
training
because the numbers aren't adding up and
you really need to get to the bottom
you need to find out where your money's
going and i can't find it i hadn't found
it in this conversation yet
so you need to get to the bottom of that
because someone that's making 76
000 should be able to save a lot more
than 400 a month when you don't have any
debt anymore
there ought to be wiggle room so rachel
the ratio that we always use is three to
six months of expenses
and so your expenses uh you know taking
her to 9 300
she said was her ideal emergency fund
that's not that far off
but the point being 9 300 as a
percentage of her
your expenses are somewhat related to
your income sure
sure i mean you know and so if you've
got if you're if you have a goal of a
ten thousand dollar emergency fund and
you make 76 000 you should be able to do
that in six to nine months
somewhere in there right if you don't
have any payments but a house payment
and that's where it shouldn't be 400 in
other words that'll be a thousand
dollars
and then you get be there very quickly
and so you
very seldom do you look at a situation
you or i
work sitting down with someone's budget
where they cannot do their baby step
three
in um six to nine months first six
months right
correct yep because it's it is three to
six months of expenses
and you're you're that as a rate it's
somewhat related to your income even
though your expenses should be lower
than your income
it's not it's not three to six months of
your income uh
but but it's it is related enough that
it ends up being a short period of time
yes but for so
for cynthia six years old she doesn't
think she'll be able to retire she's
having a tough time funding that baby
step three
and this is where we say you're still
gazelle intense like as you're paying
off debt you have that mentality of
sacrifice and
extra jobs doing it all that goes in and
bleeds into baby step three
and so even though i know she said kovid
took away that second job but
any any other income you can bring in
just to beef this up
walking alongside figuring out where
where the money's going but let's
pretend that we found
1500 of the missing 2500
a minute ago we get into it we find that
that's 18 000
a year okay that finishes her emergency
fund in six months
almost like i've done this before and
then you start saving
hundred dollars a month eighteen
thousand dollars a year uh you're not
gonna retire broke if you work seven
more years
uh that's gonna be 150 to 200 000 plus
growth
so you know you're gonna be okay but
you've got to find the missing money
that's what caused you the point of
getting out of debt is not to be out of
debt
it is but the big point about being out
of debt is then you use what you used to
pay
for so you become rich are wealthy
or more secure or more generous or all
of the above